for some insight into the military
strategy i spoke with retired u.s air
force general hawk carlisle he's in
washington
general from a military and strategic
perspective what do you make of the
russian attacks on targets in kyiv
strategically he's trying to
back nato down which i think he got
exactly opposite of what he expected he
wants to move nato away from his borders
he's getting exactly the opposite if you
look at what's happening in the baltic
states and uh on the eastern flank of
nato so
you know that's the part strategically
right now that to me is is
very concerning at what point do you
think the west moves from helping
ukraine with self-defense by providing
weapons to actually providing defense
yeah that that's a that's a tough call i
mean i if you look at the world leaders
and you look at where nato is
they really want to get to the defense
of ukraine they really believe it
because they can't allow this to go
unanswered certainly for
other authoritarian regimes like xi
jinping it would be catastrophic to
allow this to stand
but they're doing everything in their
power to do it by other means and
frankly if you look at where things are
going
um they're having some level of success
by supporting ukrainian supplies and
capability uh they're they're bolstering
the ukrainian defense and again i think
putin mr putin underestimated the
ukraine you know i think the western
powers and the leaders of the western
countries and nato are doing everything
in their power
to not give him an excuse
by putting nato troops into ukraine or
nato capability actual nato uh fighting
in ukraine but still having the same
impact of of helping defend ukraine all
at the same time diminishing russia
general you know nato carried out
airstrikes during the cost of a war in
1999 they did that without u.n approval
because it was a humanitarian
intervention at the time to stop the
slaughter of ethnic albanians
what is different in 2022 in ukraine
in this case
you have
an evil uh strategist like mr putin
that has nuclear weapons has chemical
biological weapons
[Music]
and so it's it's a different context and
of course and we're 20 years later uh
it's a different world that we live in
in 1999
china was not the power that they are
today there wasn't uh the challenges in
other parts of the world as well so i
you know i think
it's just a different scenario today
with ukraine and i think what
um the leaders in the west and nato are
doing is trying to do everything they
can
short of giving
putin the context to attack
other parts of nato especially the
baltic states which i think would be
moldova in the baltic states i think
could be his next targets
retired u.s air force general hawk
carlisle thanks